hey everybody welcome back to Pike
attacks I've decided what I want to do I
want to work on happy ko Harbor and
there's a bunch of interesting stuff
that I can talk about when it comes to
this scenario for one it is one of the
scenarios that I made but unlike most of
the scenarios that I made I didn't come
up with the title and description of
this one and I really loved the
description of it actually so it is
basically an old industrial Harbor that
you can redevelop into a theme park and
it actually has those contractual
obligations and things like that as
footnotes which I didn't even know as
possible in the descriptions I think
they just added that in here for this
scenario but that's pretty funny anyway
it's it's a pretty unique scenario
because we need to get a slightly
different goal we need to get three
coasters in the park with an excitement
rating of 50 or above I have a
decoration rating of at least 80% which
is a completely new goal but to be
honest given how I've been playing the
scenario so far I think that shouldn't
be too difficult and finally have to get
600 guests into the park so a really
cool set of goals kind of unique
compared to what we've seen so far so
let's take a look at the scenario map
itself alright so here we are this is
happy Koh Harbor and a little fun facts
I suppose that I haven't talked about
much or they haven't seen other people
talk about much either is I based the
scenario in the Netherlands actually so
you could tell at this sea level is
actually slightly higher than the height
of the land behind this dike over here
and this house I tried my best to go for
the classic Dutch red brick and orange
reddish roof combination there so this
is ideally somewhere in the Netherlands
and I was actually mostly inspired for
this scenario by a project which is
currently underway in Rotterdam I don't
know much about the future of this
project but it's called atraxi Pollock
Rotterdam and plans are underway to turn
a old garbage burning facility in
Rotterdam into a theme park
which is currently under way so that's
pretty cool but yeah that does mean that
given the setting we aren't exactly in
the Hills we're not exactly in a natural
environment and we're also in a pretty
tight spots there's not a lot of space
in this park all we have is this grassy
field here and I believe we can expand
into this section of the land as well so
that's quite good I've seen a lot of
people actually already finish this
scenario and I've seen a lot of people
work just on this part of the land so
I'm gonna have to see if I can you know
finish the objectives and a decent Park
within this or whether I also want to
use this part but we'll see what's gonna
happen to that anyway I don't think I
can do much with this theme I can't
exactly put a medieval town or some kind
of Asian scenery in the middle of this
port so I'm gonna have to try my best to
come up with a way to actually theme
this land maybe it's gonna have to be
similar to the airport theme that I went
for quite a few episodes ago but we'll
see I'm actually very curious to see
what kind of rise and coasters we have
here because I made this scenario like
over a year ago and I'm not even sure if
they changed anything yeah to be honest
I'm not exactly sure if this was always
the set of rides that we got on this
scenario but it is quite limited so I
think the first thing that our research
is coasters because we do need to get
three of those up and they need to have
a pretty high rating as well and looks
like we have decent calm rides and
thrill rides to start off with I think
this will actually be a really good map
to build some go-karts as well haven't
done that so far so yeah I have no idea
what I'm gonna make of this but let's
see although before I go on I just want
to point out this boats this is
absolutely amazing I actually got a
happy current logo on the boats and it's
super cool I I did and actually not just
the boat even on the cranes that is
really cool I built these buildings and
things like that but all of the happy co
stuff has definitely been added after
that so really nice scenery it's
actually very immersive pretty much
fully developed ports with
some industrial activities like oil
refinery and stuff like that going on
even these have signs oh they're making
tires here oh that is that is awesome
well I'm gonna I'm gonna stop talking
about the scenario and actually build
some stuff let's go all right so I
decided to do something very similar to
what I did in MIT airfield and keep the
theme of the park quite generic and
related to the port around it although I
will get into some dutch details here
and there so you might be able to tell
that it's in the netherlands but it's
not themed to be a Dutch themed park so
to speak so actually I lost a bit of
recording there because my hard drive
was completely full because the newest
planet coaster losery Gardens episode is
ridiculously big but hopefully that
thing should be out of the way pretty
soon and I can start not having to
manage so tightly my resources but
basically what you missed is me building
this food courts building which is very
simple although it does have a new
overhang which I quite like if never
tried using the cable pieces to make
hanging overhanging sections but I think
it looks really nice and elements like
this can definitely make a very simple
boring industrial building which this
pretty much is a little bit more
inviting and communicates that this is
actually a food court building where you
are invited to go inside and next to
that I decided to add the twister as
well as a small toilet building so we
got sort of a row of facades and a Main
Street and an entrance Plaza but really
it's all quite small and crammed even I
also have to say I'm gonna try it to fit
the whole park on this section of the
land just because I think I might be
able to so I want to try at least and if
it doesn't work out I can always use the
other piece of the port as well but
honestly I think it'll be fine hopefully
I should be able to fit everything on
here the reason why I think it'll be
nice to do this is to make sure that
is really compact and try and fit as
many things into this space as possible
while at the same time not making the
park feel too tight
kind of like Tivoli Gardens in
Copenhagen I've always really respected
how much that Park manages to fit in a
tiny footprint yet it doesn't really
feel like it's packed too tight
everything is nicely spaced out from
each other and there's enough paths to
walk around even when I was there during
the World Cup or actually during the
European Cup and they were showing a
match live in the middle of the park it
wasn't even too overcrowded they can
handle really large crowds for how small
the park really is so I want to go for
something similar to that here obviously
we're not in the middle of the city like
Italy is but still land is very limited
and finally to get a bit more of a
thrill ride in here
I built the drop tower and by now you
might be able to notice that I'm a
really big fan of this ride mostly just
because it fits in a very small
footprint so it's really easy to fit
this into any Park but also it's just a
very fun ride I'm not necessarily a big
flat right person I'll usually just ride
flat rides in parks between coasters or
to fill up the rest of the day when I've
already done the coasters in the park
but drop towers are definitely some of
my flight my favourites flat rides out
there and honestly sometimes even some
of my favourite rides in certain parks I
think the drop tower in roofy Park
Germany is probably the best ride in the
park so they're not too shabby as far as
flat rides are concerned and finally I
decided to start work on a monorail
station and a small piece of track but
how the rest of this monorail is gonna
flow kinda depends on what the rest of
the park is going to look like so I'm
not going to finish this yet I'll just
see how I can squiggle the monorail
track through the other areas of the
park that I'll be building so this
monorail will most likely only be
finished once I finish the rest of the
park as well so it's it's a bit of a
layouts choice because again I don't
really blend these layouts
it's I just build at any time what I
feel like building and sometimes I think
that the months some management of where
you're gonna build things and how to not
work yourself into a corner where you
have to waste some space especially
because space is very limited in this
scenario so finally it is time for the
first coaster because we do need to get
three of these and also from a gameplay
perspective I do also want to get a good
coaster in with my starting money
because these are the most important
money makers in the game and boy this
coaster turned out to be quite the
moneymaker but we'll get back to that
later basically what I decided to build
is a premier rides Li M coaster which is
an older type of coaster from the 90s
which was one of the first really
revolutionary launched coasters
I think the first ones were flight of
fear and Kings Island and Kings Dominion
and these are indoor rides so their
layouts have been built specifically to
fit into a building so they're very
compact but some later versions like
Joker's jinx for instance at one of the
Six Flags parks it kind of takes is very
similar layouts but puts it outside very
similar to rock and roller coaster in
Disneyland and Express in wannabe
Holland respectively so these layouts
tend to be very compact but do you have
a segment with a separate station and a
launch track which I thought fits very
well into this park because space is so
limited and I basically just have to the
reserved a very small part of the space
of this park to the main layout of this
coaster and also these things look
really cool from the distance I think
they they have a really cool skyline so
I thought it'd be nice to put this out
on the waterfront and have it be a
coaster to look at as well especially
for those who don't want to ride it but
still want to see other people ride the
coaster so that is basically it for this
layout the layout is actually very
similar to the Rio and I am launched
coasters as well starting off with a
cobra roll as most of them do
and from that point onward it's just a
layout of many curves and drops as well
with a corkscrew somewhere near the end
and in this ride I also decided to put a
zero-g roll in the middle of the layout
as well it's not as it's not quite as
compact as the real-life versions but to
be honest I couldn't really fit a lot
more curves into it it's also a bit
smaller so I'm limited there and I still
wanted to build something below the
coaster track as well which I'll get to
in a second for now I'm just working on
some of the basic scenery for this ride
it's not very themed but it does have
some basic scenery so I'm adding a
station and some catwalks and then it's
basically it's and before I move on I
wanted to build the right underneath it
which I decided could be the go-karts
because usually go-karts are not the
most efficient thing I would say for a
compact park like this because you're
wasting a lot of space and you're not
really using the vertical space well
enough I would say since it's completely
flat so I thought it'd be good to just
drop it underneath the coaster there's
enough space to do that and the coaster
is slightly off the ground pretty much
for the whole layout so I think that
works out really well and I just built
the go-carts coaster layout or the
go-karts layout in such a way to avoid
all of the supports of the coaster so
it's not the best layout for a go-karts
Trek but I've built it this way to make
sure that the coaster isn't under
support it's so I think it's a decent
compromise there and finally for this
parts of the playthrough I decided to
finish up some of the detailing and the
scenery around the coaster and the
go-karts first I built the balloon stall
but then I realized that you get these
weird balloons to go with it and I
didn't quite like the look of that small
building in middle of the plaza there so
I decided to replace that with a first
aid store which is a new store I haven't
seen that in any of the scenarios so far
I don't know if it's too necessary to
have it I'm not even exactly sure how it
helps in this game but I guess we'll see
I thought it fits in that space anyway
so yeah there it goes and there's not
gonna be any other rides in this area to
be honest I'm really just finishing up
some of the scenery but the focus here
is going to lie on the coaster and the
go-karts underneath it I also make this
area very vibrant with a lot of foliage
and things like that which I maybe tend
to do a bit too much especially on the
desert scenarios I still plant a lot of
trees so that may not be the most
realistic thing especially in this
setting as well because given that this
is actually an industrial site or in
this case a post-industrial site areas
like these are typically very
contaminated and the soil will be very
polluted so in real life when they are
transforming previous industrial areas
into parks or new residential areas very
typically they need to renew the soil
and make sure that everything is cleaned
and I'm not sure how that whole process
would have gone here but this park is
really surprisingly vibrant for being in
the middle of a previous industrial area
so as far as realism goes I'm not too
sure how good it is that I just planted
a bunch of birch trees and all kinds of
big other foliage elements in here
but it just looks too good not to do it
so I'm gonna keep doing that to be
honest and yeah that is basically it I'm
just finishing off this little house
here which has the what store is that
the umbrella store which is always a
good way to make money and that is
basically it for this part of the
time-lapse so let's take a quick look at
how the park is doing so happy ko Harbor
isn't doing too bad for itself and it's
mostly actually due to this coaster
which is one of the most profitable
coasters that I think of built in the
scenario so far nearly 2000 and I could
probably even raise the price on this
because it has an extreme excitement
rating so $15 is probably going to be
acceptable
I might even keep raising it just to see
how much people are willing to pay for
this thing but yeah I think the reason
that it's so efficient is that I can
basically ask a ridiculous price
but the layout is quite short and it
doesn't have to waste time on a lift
hill or anything like that it just goes
straight into the launch and into the
rest of the layout so this is what it
looks like it looks like a tangled mess
of coaster track fun facts this coaster
type is I think pretty much officially
but definitely defects are known as a
spaghetti ball coaster because they look
like spaghetti balls that is basically
about it I don't even know what the what
the history behind this is but you can
find actual articles and websites
referring to this as a spaghetti coaster
so that is pretty funny but they seem
like really fun rides I've never been on
one personally but it's it's good for
the amount of space that it takes up
really nice compact ride here and then
underneath that we have the go-karts
which has a bit too short of a queue but
altogether it's not doing too shabby
either not very profitable but it's
definitely more as a scenery thing I
think then an actual ride to bring in
the profits that said I can probably
raise the price on some of these rides
I've definitely noticed and this is
something that I mentioned in the last
video but I don't think I really went
into detail with it later but I
definitely noticed how scenery can make
your rides a lot more profitable I
always thought that my focus on scenery
was kind of counter intuitive at least
in terms of gameplay because you spend a
lot of money on scenery but really the
ratings of your rides will also go up
significantly because of scenery so if
you look at the twister for instances
has a 33.6 excitement rating whereas if
I place a new one let's say somewhere
out in the middle of nowhere
it's gonna have twenty point five so the
scenery makes a huge difference and that
is actually part of the reason why my
parks are so profitable so as I
discovered it isn't the case that my
parks are doing less good because of the
scenery but they are actually much more
successful because of scenery so highly
detailing your parks and gameplay go
kind of hand-in-hand in some ways
also and this is something that I
haven't mentioned about the scenario
itself yet but one of the one of the
ideas behind this scenario is to force
the player to focus a bit more on
scenery because of course one of the
goals is to have a decoration rating of
80 percent and as you'll notice if you
go to the visualizations and you click
on decorations all of the buildings
outside of the map of the park itself
are in purple which means that all of
these buildings are subtracting from
your decoration rating and if people see
any of these things outside the park
they will rates the decoration less
that's why I put these fences around the
entire park and wherever I could I put
some trees as well and this pretty much
solves the issue it's not a very
difficult issue to solve but I've
definitely seen players struggle with
the decoration rating of this scenario
so if you are struggling with reaching
the objectives because of that
decoration rating try to make sure that
you don't see anything that's outside
the park from inside the park itself but
yeah you can do that quite easily with
trees or fences or things like that
not with terrain because that is
actually limited you're not allowed to
change and if the terrain here but
scenery options can definitely help here
in any case that's it for what I wanted
to say here and I think it's a good time
to get into time lapse again and start
building some stuff and I hope that I
would be able to finish the scenario
with this plot of land here I need two
more coasters and I'm thinking of
building a wooden coaster around the
perimeter of the park here and then once
my research is done on the hydraulically
launched coaster built something like
cannon in Liseberg over here we'll see
if that actually fits somehow but it
sounds like a decent plan so let's go
alright so those were the famous last
words of a previous version of me a few
hours ago just before I would spend more
than two hours trying to build some
simple coasters and bike stacks and I
realized that making compact coasters
wasn't as easy as I thought it was going
to be which to be honestly usually isn't
it's very often really a puzzle of
trying to get
together because you're not just going
out to build a layout that would be fun
on its own but also you need to fit it
into a very tight space and in this case
in this scenario I'm also really limited
by the fact that I need both of these
coasters to have an excitement rating of
five as well and I can't reform so I
can't really go underground and there's
also the monorail station which for some
stupid reason I decided to build there
and I figured that instead of redoing
that whole thing and getting rid of the
monorail station I would try and work my
way around it terrible idea and that
pretty much sealed my fate but and here
we are and I'm trying to build a compact
woody so you can already see that I've
been rebuilding the station a few times
I'm gonna keep it in the current
position that it's in because I think
the first drop and the first hill at
this point are pretty much perfect I'm
just trying to make the rest of the
layouts fit into this space
without being too short either I
definitely want to get a good amount of
curves and a good amount of airtime
moments into this layouts I was inspired
by most of all a coaster called mind
blower which is a gravity group woody as
well as what I believe is called twister
and grown on land which is also a
gravity group woody I really like the
looks of these coasters they're also
very compact and they have this really
cool wooden track and steel supports
combination with the white supports
which I think looks absolutely amazing
and it's something that I don't really
do often enough so I decided to go for
that combination today instead instead
of the regular old kind of dark brown
ish completely wooden wooden coaster so
I think there's a fun variation there so
at this point in the process I came up
with the layouts so if you're thinking
that I already finished the layout and I
didn't struggle as much as I predicted
with this thing then mark my words we're
gonna come back to this thing later
because this layout isn't anywhere near
done yet because at this point I have to
figure out how to get the monorail back
into the station which was also a bit
annoying because there really is no
space at all so the only thing that I
figured out could work with this layouts
is these two curves on the side coming
back to the station a really awkward way
but it comes back to the station so I
thought it was decent and I would figure
out how to build the launch coaster
around that later for now I wanted to
get back to the supports of the wooden
coaster because due to all of the
overlapping track sections there's a lot
of floating track and I wasn't all too
happy about that so I decided to custom
support some parts of the coaster just
to make it look a bit more realistic and
make sure that we don't have these weird
floating parts and at this point I
deleted the whole layouts because I
realized that the clearance on this was
completely off so the game lets me build
that whole layouts with no problems
but then when I ran the test rounds and
I checked what it was looking like it
turned out that the the cars were
actually going through the supports on
multiple stages so basically what I did
is with a lot of very smart banking and
almost too close track pieces but not
quite with a lot of puzzling I ended up
creating a layout which didn't clear the
track properly and had the heads of the
people beheaded quite a few times on the
supports of the track above it so I
decided to remove that whole layouts
because I didn't really like how
unrealistically terrible and deadly it
looked so I wanted to change that and
that was basically the reason why I had
to go back into this and figure out a
completely different way to finish this
layout so another plan that I had was
coming back to the back of it which
gives us some good space to build some
airtime Hills only struggle here is this
curve down on the other side which is
very low to the ground and I still need
to go underneath that there's really no
other option to go anywhere else at the
back of the coaster as you can see I did
try it over here but I really didn't
think it'll look very good I wanted the
way back to be one tile right next to
the lift hill because then you are
reusing your support structure for the
lift Hill and that is a
very typical wooden coaster thing to do
I just think it looks a lot better so
that whole plan backfired I'm not going
back to the back of the park instead I'm
going in front of this other Hill trying
to figure out some other way to return
and I end up basically not going for
this curve which I thought at first was
really nice but this actually takes up a
lot of land that is very valuable
because I also need to make this coaster
as tight as possible because I need to
conserve space for the launch coaster
which I want to build after this so yeah
I was starting work on the launch
coaster here so that went pretty
smoothly I want to make this an intimate
accelerator with a very standard layout
I would say going into top hats and then
finishing the layout in whatever way I
could but then I quickly realized that
the wooden coaster was stopping me from
doing anything that I wanted to do so I
had to read change the wooden coaster
I guess free change is a word now just
to make sure that had enough space for
the launch coaster over here which I
still didn't I still had to go
underneath the wooden coaster track and
none of that worked out really well so I
had to move up the station and launch of
the launched coaster again rebuilt that
that top hat and thank God it finally
fit so I thought alright we're gonna
pull a stealth here we're just gonna go
into the top hats and then we're gonna
come back into the brakes and that'll be
the ride but then I built it and I
really wasn't too happy with this sure
it works but it's just it's just kind of
boring I thought I would be able to do
something more with it kind of like
accelerator
at Knott's Berry Farm so I set out to
make something like accelerator maybe
have a few more hills and curves before
we head back into the station and that
turned out to be quite a struggle as
well because now that the wooden coaster
is here there really isn't all that much
land left in the park and it's gonna be
hard it's actually return to the station
properly so eventually I ended up going
for the very figure 8 shape of
accelerator itself just because that
works the best I think all of these
other attempts at going to the
waterfront and over the wooden coaster
just never
really turn into anything because the
wooden coaster is completely in the way
there
so yeah I'm finding out some way to
return alongside the launch track here
so finally I get to a figure eight that
sort of works still need to adjust that
a little bit and make it fit a bit
better but altogether I think this is a
decent layout and yeah in addition to
what I'm trying to do with fitting in
the track I also need to fit in the
supports because I don't want to lose
any supports in this coaster I don't
want to have any large track sections
that are unsupported but as you might
know having any kind of ride paths trees
or really pretty much anything
underneath any of your supports removes
their supports so I need all of the
great spaces where the supports of this
ride are going to be placed to be
completely free of objects as well so
one of those curves has it supports no
just in the middle of that helix of the
wooden coaster some of the other
supports are sneaking around paths and
next to the monorail but it lasts it
finally fits and I got a layout switch
this sort of works and has a long enough
break run to realistically get the
coaster down to a decent speed without
snapping the necks of the riders so yeah
this is with a little bit of of right
footage where I was trying to figure out
stuff this is basically the process of
how I got to these coaster layouts I
know it's been a big ruling definitely
for me but also to watch so I'm sorry if
it hasn't been the most interesting
speed build but at the same time it was
too much part of this process to cut it
out I still wanted to show what this
looked like and how I was gradually
figuring out how to fit everything in
this Pike together without making it too
cramped so at this point I realized that
the monorail in the game can actually
have a back-and-forth mode instead of a
full circuits so that's amazing I didn't
know that was a thing but that makes my
life a lot easier that means that the
station of the monorail isn't as
dysfunctional as I thought it was I
could just have that thing go back and
forth between that station and another
station providing transport across the
park which is in a way kind of point
because the park is super tiny anyway
but it's a mini monorail I think it's
it's still valid I've seen smaller
amount of rails in real life so even the
monorail ended up working out in the end
and finally I can even add some flat
rides in the middle of these coasters as
well and try and fill in the park as
much as possible because really I wasn't
just trying to you know fit as much as I
could into this park I was also trying
to not make the park feel like it's too
crammed I definitely wanted to try and
make the layout in such a way that it
still feels natural and you still have a
bunch of scenery and flat rides
everywhere very much like Tivoli Gardens
in Copenhagen so yeah in the end that
was kind of my goal and that's why I
struggled so much with this as well I
probably could have built some very
simple super compact layouts of coasters
and call it a day but I definitely
wanted to try and make the most of the
limited space that I had and try and
plan very well what I would do with
every grid tile of the park so nothing
gets wasted so that's why things end up
taking a lot of time but I think that's
also a very important part of the
process of trying to puzzle a part like
this together and it really does feel
like a puzzle because when you have this
few grid spaces to play with everything
really becomes you know a jigsaw puzzle
of trying to fit different pieces
together putting the coasters together
and filling the spaces in between up
with paths and flat rides and buildings
and even making sure during the whole
process to leave enough room for things
that you still want to build like the
room that I left between the wooden
coaster and the launched coaster to try
and build some flat rides as well as the
monorail which was supposed to go
through this whole area so there's
definitely a lot of planning going on in
a playthrough like this but yeah in the
end I think it works out alrights
definitely not the best layouts but I
think these are kinds of kind of coaster
layouts that you could take out of this
park make some blueprints off and they
can still do a good
in a different Park and it won't look
like the layouts were shoehorned into a
ridiculously small footprints because of
the limitations of the pike that they
were made for what I did struggle a
little bit with was trying to fit
stations of the monorail and wooden
coaster into this area well at the same
time having some kind of Bulevar still
on the side of the sea here so what I
ended up going for is a very small queue
on the monorail and a back and forth the
smoke kettle pan in the middle of the
wooden coaster here where I also want to
put a building here so that just adds to
the the scenery of the area as well also
I haven't mentioned this but as probably
should the flat rides that I put in are
the Gravitron and the motion simulator
which aren't my favorite flat rides but
to be completely honest they are the
only ones that fits in that space I had
a lot of research done and every time
the research teams just gave me really
big flat rides that I couldn't do
anything with and I was just like guys
please give me something with a small
footprint so I eventually just ended up
placing these things because they fit
best especially the the motion simulator
that thing just fits anywhere I really
love that net footprint so yeah I would
have probably placed a jumper or some
kind of more interesting flat ride into
these areas if I could but realistically
there's really no space for it I even
even trying to place those bigger flat
rides made me realize just how small
this park is because they were on their
own just taking up space of maybe half
the size of the launch coasters whole
day on its so yeah that didn't go very
well some of the flat rides in this game
really are quite big now we're getting
to some slightly more exciting parts
again now that all of the coasters and
the stupid puzzling action is done it's
time to get back into scenery and for
this building I figured out I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna build one building
with a slightly Dutch flair to it we are
in the Netherlands Arthur oh I I can't I
can't leave it behind I'm nationalist
like that so we're building very much as
kind of house here with the traditional
green wooden walls and those typical
charming whites Gables and the red roofs
it's just iconic combination I really
love it and even though I'm not going
for anything to aggressively touch it's
just the use of materials and colors I
think that that definitely takes you
back to the fact that they say this park
is supposed to be somewhere in the
Netherlands even though that's not per
se the theme of the park itself and then
for the the building over the Q I'm
keeping that simple it's a cute cover
realistically those things aren't too
often very well themed so I'm keeping
this as simple as I can really although
that said I think the station building
if the wooden coaster is by far the most
decorated building of the park but I
think it fits the the wooden coaster as
well I ended up going for a sort of
high-tech station on the launch coaster
because that's one of those high-tech
rides it just feels right for it and the
same goes sort of for the other launch
coaster but that one already is a bit
more traditional but this one for the
wooden coaster is definitely the weenie
of the park if you will I should also
say the reason partly that I didn't go
for a Cano Ninh like intamin launch
coaster like I said I would go earlier
is because I was looking at Conan and
I've pretty much realized that I was
doing just about the same thing that the
the other launch coaster the spaghetti
ball coaster does you know just launch
your your riders into some inversions
and curves and that's pretty much it so
because those rides are very similar I
decided to go for a ride that focuses
more on the sensation of speed so this
ride is now more like accelerator and
stealth and Top Thrill Dragster etc just
a really small version to be sure to fit
it into this park and in this whole last
section of the scenario this is also
quite interesting I had to redo a bunch
of things about the wooden coaster
because I didn't meet the 50 excitement
rating
bacteria so basically I have to make
sure that the the park gets a good
scenery rating which isn't too difficult
you really just have to make sure that
you don't see anything outside of the
park from inside the park but as soon as
you just build a few scenery elements
you should be good to go on that one
what I didn't realize was that from the
coaster you can see everything outside
of the park so this wooden coaster had a
bad scenery rating even though there's a
lot of scenery around it because you can
see the outside of the park and we've
got all of these terrible industrial
buildings giving us a negative rating
here so I decided I need to do something
about that and hide all of those
industrial buildings so what I came up
with here is to build these fences or
really these wooden walls on the side of
the wooden coaster which are usually
built as sound protection to protect the
neighborhood around it from the sounds
coming off the coaster but in this case
I'm using it to prevent the guests of
the park from seeing the unholy
industrial area that is just outside the
parks boundaries so a bit of a different
thing here I also added some extra white
supports to the coaster for good measure
I think that just makes the whole
support structure look a little bit
nicer and even supporting some parts of
the coaster a little bit more and
finally I added some lights and flags on
the lift hill to make that a bit fence
here because wooden coasters with
decorations on the Left hills are
awesome and that is pretty much it for
this scenario so let's see how it's
doing now alright so here's the park
it's doing not too shabby
and I think this is also the first time
ever that I can show the whole park in a
single screen just because this one is
so tiny now I should be reaching the
goal pretty quickly because I need to
get to 600 people and I've already
reached the other objectives so that
should be fine and one last look at the
coasters just to check their stats
basically tells us that this one has
decent stats I would say although this
first launch coaster is definitely the
best stats with an extreme excitement
rating and then the wooden coaster has
50.5 which is
just enough to make the scenario but
it's really not quite as bad or quite as
good and the decoration is still bad but
I don't think I can really do anything
about this because it's just too close
to the park border and if anything it is
really trying to shield the rest of the
park from the terrible ugly industrial
wasteland that lies behind it so there's
another thing which I think is worth
noting before I reach the goal here
which I'll probably do first anyway is
that I did do a poll and somebody
suggested to do some kind of pour for
favorite coasters and stuff like that on
the last video and I don't know if they
meant to do the in-game poem but I
thought it would be interesting to
actually do the market research and this
is usually something that you can use to
try and figure out what you can improve
your Park but in this case I'm just
using this to figure out you know how
did the park do in the end and what are
people thinking about it so they they
actually think the prices are fair I
have to say I raised the price on this
thing to sixteen dollars at some point
and that was too steep for them so
definitely went too far there
they do prefer some slightly intense
rights that's definitely good to know
actually they're not super hungry which
i guess is good not super thirsty either
I think the park is really clean that's
really nice decoration rating is
actually really high despite the wooden
coaster being bad and vandalism isn't
too bad and the top thoughts are that
the scenery is amazing
ah that's awesome so yeah I really like
these stats actually that says this is a
part of research which I haven't shown
before simply because I haven't made use
of it but it is definitely something to
keep in mind and I do know for a fact
that different scenarios will have
different guests preferences especially
for when it comes to what kind of
intensity they prefer on rides what kind
of food or drink preferences they have
and even how much money they carry so
the guests on mystic Oasis really are
richer than the guests on the other
pikes for instance now I was hoping to
get to 600 guests here because I was
well marketing the poke pretty
aggressively but I think we're not quite
there yet but if I fast forward for a
few seconds I think we should be getting
there eventually
yeah they're slowly getting in in larger
numbers than they are leavings that's
good I'm not gonna do the old trick of
closing the park entrance by putting a
no entry sign in front of it I'm gonna
try my best to never make use of that
strategy because that is just unethical
even if it did work quite one roller
coaster [ __ ] so yeah here we go that is
the scenario successfully Oh Mike okay
I'm gonna have to hold this for three
weeks well I'll see you guys in three
weeks time in the meantime let's
actually do some POVs and stuff like
that so uh here's the wooden coaster
it's not doing too bad it definitely has
a few parts where you can tell that I
was trying to cram this in a tiny space
but I definitely think that this is the
best layout that I came up with and it's
a little bit slow on this part because
we have to cover a lot of ground there
but not too slow there's a decent
airtime Hill with the tunnel here and
finally with an S Bend back over the
queue and back into the station and I
hope that we can catch a ride on the
launched coaster
looks that way I think it's in the
station at the moment yet so okay it's
launching very nice actually turn off
the UI for a second here see that that
is the launched coaster doesn't catch
too much air time on the top hats but
again coming back to the discussion of
the last episode I think for me at least
the speed of a lot of these rides feel
fine scaled to the cartoony size of
everything in the game I think it would
be interesting maybe to build one of
these coasters and planet coaster and
try to do it on the same scale that I
imagine these coasters on and see if the
speeds are different in any way I
definitely think that the coasters in
Park tech speed up and slow down a
little bit faster but it's really not
quite as fast as coasters would be
enrolling or certai kun for instance and
I think it's really the comparison to
roller coaster tycoon that makes them
feel slow here
anyway that's it we reach the goals for
this scenario and I finally caught the
confetti for this one on camera so uh
yay did that at last also now let's do a
quick POV of this one I always forget to
follow the coasters I also got some
questions on the last video still why I
don't do unright videos basically the
game doesn't have on right POVs from the
get-go you can't get a mod for that but
I want to keep this a vanilla
playthrough just to make sure that I
don't misrepresent anything of the game
or cheat my way through the scenarios
and also for me personally I prefer to
keep the game in isometric mode it's not
meant to be looked at from 3d
perspective and in in a way for me it
kind of breaks the immersion of the game
itself it's part of the attraction at
least for me is the isometric
perspective and the distance that you
keep from this stuff that you're
building so yeah those are my choices
for not doing any actual unright POV
shots but I think following the coasters
is decent enough anyway let's get back
into the main map and see what else we
got I don't know what scenario we're
gonna go next so I'm probably gonna go
for Biscayne Beach but I'm still curious
to see what the new scenario is gonna be
if it's a fun one I might play that one
instead so as a trophy we get one of the
cranes of the harbor oh and even builds
a little hardware platform over here
that is pretty cool oh and we get a
bunch more all right that is that is
really nice so we got not one but two
new scenarios here so it's gonna be oh
yeah it's gonna be difficult to choose
which one I want to play so highway
hijinks is another one that Joshua made
I only added some scenery to this map
but it's really Joshua's map and then
honey Hills is one of the maps that I
made if I recall correctly this is one
of the first ones that I ever made gotta
click on that just whenever it passes by
I just can't help but click on it so
either one of these would be really fun
I think
I think our weights with Biscayne Beach
because I just got done with quite a
bunch of tropical maps and I think
highway hijinks would be a really
interesting once it's right for now so
I'm not entirely sure if I'm gonna do
that for the next episode or just
depends on what I feel like when I start
recording at one but it's probably going
to be highway hijinks
in any case hope you guys enjoyed this
episode and I hope to see you guys next
time